one of the stars of Brooklyn nine-nine
now in its fifth season and premiere
just last week it airs every Tuesday
night 9:30 Eastern on Fox but there's so
much more to Terry Crews than just
Brooklyn nine-nine how how good a
football player were you because
sometimes the older you get the better
you were yeah when you you nobody was
around of watch or remembers and then
you could say whatever I I was I was
good enough to be an NFL I watched a lot
of superstars go home but but in regard
to being a Pro Bowl player I was that in
my mind but it just didn't get there you
know what I mean where did you go to
college I went to Western Michigan
University okay but you got to
understand - it was it was kind of weird
for me because I never I it was I play
defensive end in college and then in the
pros I was switched to linebacker so it
wasn't something I grew up doing I was
just a tremendous athlete that was kind
of put into a spot then I really you
know didn't have experience I had played
linebacker all the way from high school
all the way through I think I would have
done better to be honest with you but
you ever have a moment in the NFL where
you say that that's it right there
Oh there were several like when I was
with the skins and I was backing up Ken
Harvey and I remember he went down and I
went in we were playing the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and I went in and made three
consecutive amazing tackle it was it was
awesome he jumped off the gurney jumped
off and ran back in the game I was like
see this is literally my best friend to
this day he is my best friend he's
actually coming up to New York to
visited me today but we always talked
about that he was like you know I fell
is the kind of place where you wish your
best friend got injured you know I mean
you want your best friend to really get
a concussion and so you can you can get
your chin yeah and totally he came back
in a game and that was it for me he was
a beast now he was a Pro Bowl player now
who's the biggest name you tackled Barry
Sanders you act
no you he we played against you get a
touch wait for him to go down and you're
like oh my god but again to play against
him was an amazing amazing experience
you know I mean yeah I came in NFL in 91
which was it was kind of wild because I
was actually at the game when Mike Utley
got hurt you know and it never walked
again and then the same game a friend of
mine lost the tip of his finger and I'm
rebels on the way play on the plane on
the way home like oh my god this is like
this is like life or death you know what
I mean that was a real eye-opener for me
so it was the old school kind of kind of
feel I mean we had some guys in the
locker room I was smoking cigarettes
yes cigarettes okay straight cigarettes
in the locker room nobody's drinking or
anything no drinking until after the
game but it was totally cigarettes in
the locker room I was like holy cow
weird when does acting then all of a
sudden come into play now acting I never
wanted to act ever I was again I was an
art major I was painting drawing and the
whole thing and I thought I would want
to get behind the scenes in regard to
creative you know like writing and even
special effects I had my portfolio in at
Disney as an animator when I first came
out to Hollywood but we went broke we
had no money and a friend of mine
invited me to an audition and it was a
show called battle dome which was like
American Gladiators on steroids I mean
we were sending people to the hospital
it was pre MMA but you were allowed to
be on steroids on this show we beat
people day it was American glad it was
nice and and very calm I played a
character named t-money who was this
warrior from Detroit who would literally
smash you in the head that was the whole
point of battle dome to the logline for
the show was called real warriors real
pain
and but see people weren't used to see
him blood on TV at the time you know
after you know the UFC really hit it
became a more of a bloodlust type thing
but we were like pre that hodizzle
contestants would come in they put me in
a cage set the ends on fire and you had
to try to wrestle me out of the cage but
I didn't want to go and it was it was
violent it was brutal and it only lasted
two years because I don't think people
were ready they just were like okay it's
too much this is weird
so your break then came where that was
it that was the break but then what
happened after that then after that I
became a heel like people got to know me
as a badass this whole thing and Arnold
Schwarzenegger was looking for a new
kind of badass to you know be a part of
this posse in his movie and I took it I
got an audition first movie I ever
auditioned for is called the sixth day
and I got it and I thought okay I was
gonna kill me it'll be about like a week
it'll be good and dude turns out I spent
six months in Vancouver I was one of the
main characters in the in the movie it
was used and Arnold did eventually kill
me but you know I was in his nice space
at the time he was like I don't want to
be that divided anymore it was like the
first pg-13 I was like damn I wanted
r-rated Arnold you know what I mean
but it was it was a less violent movie
it was good it was all about cloning and
all that but I was off to the races let
me tell you and I never stopped acting
after that after that I had to learn
what I was doing I remember Michael
Rooker was on a set like I didn't know
what I was doing I had no idea and but
again I have a superpower which is being
unembarrassed ball so I just I was able
to go and didn't a comedy thing started
to click Terry Crews one of the stars of
Brooklyn nine-nine and in his fifties
and we were actually in a movie together
we were in blended with Adam Sandler yes
and you stole the end of the movie that
was supposed to be which I never got a
chance to yell at you
my TV show you can't do you get any
times we had a ball maybe way back here
and Longest Yard together did you do a
cameo in training day ah yes I did yes I
did let me tell you how that well I I
battle dome was what was filmed in the
LA sport's arena okay which is right
next to the jungle which is right where
a training day was filmed so all the
gang members will come watch we would be
part of the studio audience limit let me
take a break okay yeah because I do have
a point to make about training days I
don't know if you're gonna agree with me
okay it's controversial but continue
it's on you and Fritzi are gonna take
your shirts off and you're gonna get
oiled either I don't want to see fritzy
Buddha sure you do not those are the
Guns of Navarone will continue with
Terry Crews right at seton could you get
the oil like would you ever have
somebody's job to put oil on you if you
were working out like posing oh yeah you
gotta have oil I never go out in the
morning without an oil boiled does a guy
do that for you it's a very personal
thing
almost all natural right there Terry
Crews one of the stars of Brooklyn
nine-nine back with more right after
this
been in a lot of different movies a lot
of different sitcoms played the
president but you're an extra in
training days right okay first time you
meet Denzel Washington how's that go you
know I remember shaking his hand
he was studying his lines and he kind of
was like I'm busy you know yeah and you
don't want to get in his way it was we
were writing you're an extra yeah I am
an extra you know but this thing know
when I met him I wasn't even in the
movie it was crazy
I came because a friend of mine was a
location manager because I used to do
security on movie sets so he showed he
introduced me to the set and there he
was are you watching denzel he's in the
jungle he's doing his thing
but all the gang members recognize me
from the show battle dome and so the
director these are real Gangnam there's
a real game every day when we would film
in the Sports Arena we shot it at the
Sports Arena right down by USC yeah and
uh so dave says that no gang signs
please no so the director notices all
these these members gang members in the
jungle like coming up to me he said hey
man you wanna be in this movie and I was
like yeah yeah hey man take your shirt
off here we gonna go up to the roof and
I took my shot I'm the guy who's
clipping pigeons and that iconic scene
in training today and then he said come
back now I didn't get paid for anything
he said come back the directors to come
back every day and I'll find a way to
put you in the movie and so that big
scene at the end when denzel's going off
and the whole thing's I want you
standing right in front of Denzel and
that was me and the black tank top
standard Mad Dog and Denzel now this is
the deal I ruined the movie for
everybody now because they're like
that's the guy from white chicks used to
be a really threatening scary oh my god
and so as the years go on it scared a
wild you know it's kind of oh boy
oh yeah I wonder you know but but the
good thing was is that that was the
first time I was actually in the Academy
Awards and I was looking at my we were
watching the Oscars and there are
with Denzel and I was like and I would
have been happy never doing anything
else but the again the career just took
off after that I think Ethan Hawke was
better than Denzel on that movie yeah he
was great because his role was a whole
lot tougher
Denzel played that was his Pacino
Scarface mom oh yeah yeah but Ethan has
to he's sort of the newbie and then all
of a sudden you don't know if denzel's
playing with him and then he realizes
what they're doing now he's all in now
he has to turn around and catch the guy
who was his mentor but you know what you
got a look at movies like that where
it's kind of like when you go back to
poke fiction I mean you know Travolta
was was nominated for an Oscar but that
was Sam Jackson's movie yes you know
what I mean so that happens a lot you
know what I mean it's kind of like who's
carrying it who's reacting a lot of
times you know who gets to judge that
you know but uh I think I think that
Denzel should have got the the Oscar for
the movie he did the year before about
the boxer um because he didn't see got
slighted on that and so they gave it to
him for training day because he didn't
get it for hurricane which was awesome
so but it's crazy wonderful but but they
you know we didn't give it to you last
time so we're gonna give it did you earn
it this time or did you earn it last
time and then we made the mistake first
of all you got to remember like movies
are like you know it's all subjective
this is all American Idol you know what
I mean it's not like sports or sports is
like 1410 you lose I think he made a
choice the dude I don't agree with and
then all of a sudden nobody likes that
part of it you know and so it's like my
favorite movies are Sandler movies and
yeah people who hate Salem yeah so you
know what can you say you can't please
everybody what's Andy Samberg like on
Brooklyn nine-nine Oh Andy Andy so
amazed that first of all uh the reason I
work with Andy was because he's the
future you know what I mean he was
coming off of SNL and you know he had
his famous skit with Justin Timberlake
dick in a box which was I thought
anybody who's willing to do that I'm
down I'm like I'm down
and they went there you know I go there
I'm very extreme in the things that I
tend to do and uh and when I knew it was
Andy he is absolutely the most giving
comedic guy cuz um I've worked with a
lot of comedians and it's really hard
when you work with comedian sometimes
they're jealous territorial you know
what I mean it's like you you know you
if you get all the laughs and the crew
is laughing at you all of a sudden you
just disappear you know I mean and it's
just very like but Andy's not like that
guy he's always been sharing and giving
this is why ensemble of Brooklyn high
nine works so well we did a movie with
him that's my boy yes and and I'm in the
scene where I'm this talk show host I'm
trying to get this exclusive interview
and they're in prison and I remember we
got done with our we did one scene and
then we were gonna do it again in
Sandburg who didn't know who the dan
ants were but he started giving advice
he didn't really know who we were but he
knew that Sandler liked me okay and then
he said you know you might you might
want to try it this way
cuz I don't know what I'm doing all
right like I'm all yours Sandler doesn't
tell you anything no no no and I go okay
and then I I think he wants to say
something to the Dan ants but he doesn't
know if they're just extras right but
then he sees Sandler talking to him then
he feels like it's okay to go over and
talk to these guys giving us some advice
we still screwed it up he was very
generous that's the point he's that guy
who's who's the guy in Hollywood you'd
like to fight Oh
could you take the rock you know no no
no could not he's my brother
you know if you had to oh my god that's
what kind of question first of all you
know what I'm a lover I know you are but
you do kick his ass too wait now I can I
bring this up this is good the big this
is a good thing because it's kind of
like these are these MMA questions you
know people do
octagons you and grantee court or and
you in it and everybody likes to do that
kinda take Randy Couture but this is the
deal and you got to understand that at
any given day you can get your ass
kicked by the by and it's weird because
if you are not in the right position or
right not right place when's the last
time you got beat up Oh in college I'll
never forget I went up against this you
know I got a fight in practice and this
guy was a wrestler
no no the guy got cauliflower ear all
the mo see this is the humility thing
this is why you can't say like you
answering questions like that somebody
who knows who's actually been beat up
because any given day you can get your
ass kicked you think you could take JJ
what oh no no way he's too young
no you know I'd shoot him I just have to
shoot him some guys are just too
powerful you'd be like hey man I got my
bye bye could you take off if I said you
had to fight all for my denims ah at the
same time yeah yeah these guys you can
see by the look in their eyes you know
what I mean when they look at you and
you look at them series and they go hi
one guy and he just doesn't break it
you're like okay you know what there's
no it's not gonna be in its the thing
when do fights end this is a question
like so we it's kinda like you can fight
fight fight but then soon as you think
it's over he might pick up something or
somebody to pull you apart
come get me yeah there's a whole dance
that has to happen you got to make sure
you got enough people to pull it your
way
cuz if you leave two people to fight
alone they'd be like I'm an you know you
want to fight now let's just talk it
over
it's only when other people drink
somewhere you're working on Brooklyn
nine-nine what else you working on oh my
god I got a movie called where's the
money
coming out in October and I guess that
way that's with a huge internet
Instagram superstar named Andrew
bachelor and king bat she's got like 15
million Instagram followers and it's a
really really fun movie and I'm too
heavy and it just all good dinner
I did another Sundance movie called
sorry to bother you that's gonna be out
in Sundance uh you know come January I'm
doing independent stuff and you know
we're doing more old spice you know you
don't world twice no spice a bit I'm an
eight year vet with Old Spice man I love
those but what do you want me I know
your marriage but what do women say when
they see I'm not for the women dude it's
too aggressive they're they're a little
bit okay all right all right
a lot of blinking he's that guy okay I'm
gonna be over here you know at your age
take off your shirt for you yes I mean
it's nice to have somebody who's ripped
in here with me because obviously look
at these guys you know I always look at
sports culture you know you you got to
look at sports as inspirational you know
I mean if I always want to tell people
when you're watching sports let it
motivate you to work out you know
because if you see if it's the date you
you can be in trouble you know I've seen
guys that are like 700 pounds and
telling people what to do my guys are
not in bad shape they're not bad you
know but I've seen some really well take
that Oh
that's sort of a compliment shape is the
best thing we're just being average as
the new up Terry Crews one of the stars
of Brooklyn nine-nine on its fifth
season premiered just last week every
Tuesday night 9:30 Eastern on Fox great
see again maybe I'll see you in another
Sandler movie thank you thanks for
stopping in the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience